hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we'll be answering the question
how similar are German and Dutch wait
what were those two languages again
german dutch dutch nederlands flumps
Dutch isn't it strange that English
speakers call the language of the
Netherlands and Flanders Dutch while
German speakers call their own language
Deutsch why is that it's because there's
a connection between Dutch and German
both are Germanic the English word Dutch
used to refer to continental Germanic
peoples in general but then came to
refer to only the people of the
Netherlands because of greater contact
and rivalry with them in particular the
English word comes from the middle dutch
word du CH and in modern Dutch Dutch
which means German and this is a cognate
of the German word Dutch and with that
we've already begun comparing the two
languages in Dutch they say Dutch and in
German they say Dutch Germanic and Dutch
are both members of the West Germanic
branch of the Germanic language family
both developed from the same root the
same ancestor language proto-germanic
which developed into western eastern and
northern dialect groups the western
dialects are the ancestors of Dutch and
German and the other West Germanic
languages one thing we have to keep in
mind when comparing Dutch and German is
that there are many dialects of Dutch
and there are many dialects of German
and in northern Germany and parts of
Netherlands there are dialects that
arguably form another language low
German or low Saxon and there's another
regional language called Frisian but
speakers of all of these dialects learn
either standard Dutch or standard German
depending on which country they live in
so there may be cases when German and
Dutch speakers understand each other
more easily when their dialects are
closer to each other but there are other
situations in which their dialects are
further apart and it would be easiest to
communicate in the standard languages in
this video I'll focus on standard Dutch
and standard German vocabulary Dutch and
Germans share a large amount of cognate
vocabulary according to one source I've
seen their lexical similarity is around
84 percent which is slightly lower
than Spanish and Italian or Spanish and
Portuguese 84% lexical similarity
doesn't mean that 84% of the words are
exactly the same it means that they are
cognates they come from a common origin
but they may have a different form or be
pronounced differently some examples the
word for glass in German nos and in
Dutch plus the word for water in German
masa and in Dutch latter the word for
dog hunt hint the word for brother
Budda Budda but this here is actually an
archaic form of the word the modern form
of the word is lure the word for sister
semester sister this is also an archaic
form the modern form is just and here
are a couple of phrases good morning
guten morgen guten morgen a good day or
good afternoon guten tag who da da it's
sunny it's sunny the dish Zuma's there
are a lot of cognates like that but
there are false cognates as well in
Dutch je means sea and mere means lake
in German Zi means lake and mia means
sea but there's actually a bit more to
it than that there's actually a
masculine word desi meaning lake and a
feminine word Deezy meaning sea in Dutch
Leeson means to lie as in to tell a lie
in German Leegin means to lie as in to
lie down on a bed for example in Dutch
listen means to lie on something like a
bed in German lugan means to tell a lie
in Dutch pain 'let means painful but in
German kindness normally means
embarrassing in Dutch motion means be
allowed to and in German Mugen means to
like but hold on a second the Dutch word
can also be used with the meaning to
like specifically when you like a person
the German word is used more generally
for people or things you like so even
though a lot of cognates may be obvious
or easy to decipher as
zooming that they mean the same thing
might cause some confusion pronunciation
I'm sure you noticed that most of those
cognate words sounded a little different
and some of them sounded quite different
one of the biggest differences between
Dutch and German is the different sounds
in either language and how these results
in cognate words that sound different
some of the differences between Dutch
and German are a result of the High
German consonant shift which took place
in the few hundred years leading up to
the ninth century German descent from
dialects that were affected by these
changes while Dutch descends from
dialects that were not affected by these
changes because of the shift voiceless
stops putas and cut in Dutch tend to be
fricatives fossa and huh in German
cognates when between vowels or after a
vowel at the end of a word for example
the words meaning shift in Dutch skip
and in German shoes and the words
meaning water in Dutch batter and in
German masa and the pronoun meaning I in
Dutch ik and in German II these same
voiceless stops became affricates
fuh-fuh or cup at the beginning of a
word or if they were doubled consonants
or if they came after an L or R sound
for example the words for Apple in Dutch
okay and in German that's a and the
words meaning heart in Dutch heart and
in German that's the third change cook
changing to
occurred only in upper German dialects
and not in standard German another shift
also took place in the voiced stops but
duh and go which became voiceless ha ha
and cut but with only the duct a tough
shift taking place in standard German
the other changes only took place in
Upper German dialects for example the
word for day in Dutch das and in German
tack remember before when I said that
certain German speakers would have an
easier time understanding Dutch because
of their dialects well that's especially
true for low German dialects because
like Dutch they didn't undergo this high
Germanic consonant shift
there was another sound change that
affected high german but also low German
and Dutch and the became duh
this explains why German still has a
sound even though there was an earlier
shift from dota there are also other
sound differences that are not a result
of the high Germanic consonant shift
notice the different G sounds in the
word for God in Dutch halt and in German
good the German gut is more or less like
the English gut the Dutch sound varies
depending on the region but is a velar
or uvular fricative you may have also
noticed that the W sounded different in
the words for water so let's hear those
again in Dutch latter and in German
Massa the German sound is similar to the
V sound in English the Dutch W is
pronounced differently in the beginning
or in the middle of the word it's sort
of between of and a what sound but at
the end of a word after a vowel
it's a glide just like W in English our
sounds are sounds very quite a lot in
either language depending on where the
speakers from but they're often
different in either language for example
the word for year in Dutch yar and in
German yeah in the Dutch word the final
R sounds like a retroflex approximate
rah like in some varieties of English
but other speakers say it as a trill dar
and when it's not at the end of the word
the trill dar is more consistently used
especially in northern areas and in the
German word the R is pronounced as a
vowel it's also pronounced as a vowel in
some other contexts like between vowels
or after a long vowel and before another
consonant in other contexts it's more
like a voiced uvular fricative haha at
least in a standard accent of germany
here's another example using the words
meaning rough in Dutch whoo here you can
clearly hear the trill dar and in German
so some consonants are spelled the same
but sound different some are spelled
differently and sound different and
others are spelled differently but sound
the same one example is that is spelled
as Zed in Dutch but as s in German
German s is also pronounced so at the
end of a word or
four consonants other than L and nasals
two words we saw earlier are German Zuni
and Dutch Zoomer there are many
differences in vowels as well some are
spelled differently but sound basically
the same like the words meaning year
that we saw a minute ago let's hear
those again and focus on the vowel in
Dutch yarr and in German yeah
notice that the vowel is spelled
differently another example the words
meaning good in Dutch hoot and in German
good there are also a lot of pairs of
cognates in which the vowel sounds have
become different and that is reflected
in their spelling for example the words
for dream in Dutch bloom and in German
home a long oval in Dutch often
corresponds with this diphthong in
German the words meaning body but
cognate with the English word life in
Dutch life and in German light these
dipthongs often correspond with each
other another similar example is the
word for bite in Dutch baton and in
German bison also notice this German
letter that represents the sound after
long vowels or diphthongs as opposed to
SS after short vowels this orthographic
symbol doesn't exist in Dutch in Dutch
so is always represented by a single s
and it's worth noting that this symbol
is not used in Swiss standard German
either they always write it as a SS
grammar there are some important
similarities and some important
differences between the grammar of the
two languages one difference is their
use of grammatical gender German has
three genders masculine feminine and
neuter which applied to nouns their
articles and adjectives that modified
them Dutch historically had the same
three genders but in practice in modern
Dutch masculine and feminine essentially
form a single common gender so the only
grammatical distinction is between
common gender and neuter and related to
that German has three definite articles
while Dutch has two and four indefinite
articles German has just two and Dutch
has just one
another difference is that German has
known cases different forms of nouns
depending on their function in the
sentence the four cases in German are
nominative genitive dative and
accusative Dutch used to have noun cases
but they fell out of use in the spoken
language and in the 1940s they were
dropped from the standard language now
they appear in some older idioms but
that's about it
that lack of noun cases arguably makes
Dutch easier to learn than German at
least in that particular way oh and
remember a minute ago when I said that
German has three definite articles well
it's actually not that simple
each definite article has some
variations depending on the nouns case
let's look at the nominative and
accusative cases just to illustrate
these sentences mean the red fish is
expensive in German the hota fish is
toya and in Dutch the rodas this is dude
as you can see these sentences can be
translated word-for-word from English
the function of the phrases meaning the
red fish is nominative because that's
the subject of either sentence these
sentences mean I like the red fish in
German he's marked in houghton fish and
in Dutch a cow from the Lodha fish hear
the phrases meaning the red fish or the
direct object which means their function
is accusative you can see that in Dutch
the noun phrase stays the same
despite its accusative function in the
sentence but in German the accusative
form is different the noun itself
doesn't have a special ending that's
different depending on the gender in the
case but the definite article changes
and the adjective has a special ending
when you consider the different case
forms for nouns articles and adjectives
there are a lot of possible combinations
these are for definite noun phrases and
these are for indefinite noun phrases
learning the different case forms is a
challenge for learners of German but if
you learn Dutch you don't have to
memorize all those different forms and
endings which affect nouns adjectives
articles and possessives etc word order
in the sentence we just saw the word
order was essentially the same in both
languages and both were the same as in
English in the following sentences they
share the same syntax but they're
different from English these sentences
mean I can play the piano very well
German estancia good Clavius peanin and
in Dutch it commutes beyond Oh Salem
word for word both sentences are I can
very good piano play in both sentences
the conjugated verb an auxilary verb
comes second after the subject both
languages feature v2 word order and in
both languages the unconjugated verb
moves to the end for clarity let's
simplify those previous sentences by
removing the adverb phrase so now they
mean I can play the piano in German each
tank knavish Pilon and in Dutch it
campeones Pelham now let's add something
so that they mean I want to be able to
play the piano in German ich mr. clavier
spielen cunnin word-for-word it's I want
piano play be able to and in Dutch equal
piano Kunis Palin word-for-word it's I
want piano be able to play in Dutch when
another auxiliary verb is added this
auxiliary verb to knee gets moved back
but the main lexical verb is still at
the end in German the equivalent
auxiliary verb gets moved to the end
after the lexical verb this same
difference occurs in relative clauses
these sentences mean he knows that I can
play the piano in German and vice
Despina VHB Lincoln word-for-word it's
he knows that I piano play can and in
Dutch hi vaids don't take piano comes
failing word-for-word it he knows that I
piano can play so while the word order
is generally similar there are some
differences in the details like that
let's look at one more final sentence
and see what we find
let's compare two sentences meaning if I
had enough money I'd buy a car first in
Dutch also exclusion so we can auto
copan word-for-word it's if I enough
money had would I a car buy next in
German Venice canoe Caqueta
Verdi ich mir ein how talk often what
forward it's if I enough money had would
I myself a car by these are both
conditional sentences with two clauses
and if
Klaus and the main clause first you
might notice that even though I said
both languages have v2 word order
neither of these sentences seem to have
verbs in the second position in the
first clause the verb comes last and in
the second clause the verb comes first
well this here is the main clause or
independent clause so we should focus on
this when thinking about v2 word order
if this clause alone were the entire
sentence then the subject would come
first and the verb would come second
making it v2 word order this here is the
dependent clause in other words it's not
a sentence by itself it only adds
information to the main clause so this
whole dependent clause occupies the
first position and in the main clause
the verb moves before the subject to
occupy second position making it v2 word
order first we can see that the words
for if are different then we have the
slightly different cognates meaning I
hear we have cognate words meaning
enough notice that the vowels sound the
same but are spelled differently and
notice that the letter G looks the same
but sounds different in Dutch the G
sounds are uvular fricative ha next we
have the cognate words for money
the next word is an important one in
Dutch this if Clause simply has the past
tense form of the verb hebben meaning to
have in German however this is a
subjunctive verb form something that
Dutch doesn't have subjunctive forms are
used to express hypothetical situations
express doubt or express something you
wish were true next we see the auxiliary
verbs in the main clause which both
translate as would the German word is
the past subjunctive form of Vanden and
the Dutch word is the past tense of
zulan which by the way is a cognate of
the English word shall notice that in
German there's an extra word here this
word is a reflexive pronoun which is
used to show that you are buying
something for yourself this is the
dative form of the first person singular
pronoun this is not completely necessary
but is commonly used in this context in
standard Dutch the reflexive pronoun is
not used here next we have the
indefinite articles which are cognates
the German one though is the neuter
accusative form while in Dutch there's
only one form of the indefinite article
next the word for car is similar the
Dutch word is in the common gender in
other words historically masculine or
feminine the German word is neuter
gender and in the accusative form but
this form takes no special ending to
distinguish it for some genders in cases
it does and for others it doesn't
finally we see the word for by köppen in
Dutch Kelvin in German the German
consonant sound foe is a result of the
high Germanic consonant shift that we
talked about earlier and also noticed
the different vowel sound there are a
lot of similarities between those two
sentences we just looked at but there
are also a lot of differences probably
enough for you to realize that to a
large extent German and Dutch are not
mutually intelligible for people who
haven't been exposed to the other very
much
words in isolation or short phrases
might be mutually intelligible but when
mixed in with different words and when
spoken at full speed it becomes much
harder and just like with other pairs of
closely related languages speakers of
Dutch and German often say that they can
understand the other language much more
in its written form than in its spoken
form and like I said earlier in the
video speakers of certain dialects might
have a much easier time understanding
the other language the question of the
day for native speakers of Dutch or
German how well do you understand the
other language and if you've ever
studied the other language what was your
experience like and for other people
after seeing the examples in this video
what's your impression of Dutch and
German do they seem very similar to you
be sure to follow Lange focus on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and once
again
thank you to all of my patreon
supporters especially these amazing
people right here on this screen they
are my top tier patreon supporters so
many many special thanks to them and to
everyone else thank you for watching and
have a nice day
[Music]